and hey there
[Music]
I was gonna three two one you
and three two hey there welcome to Conan
O'Brien needs a friend uh we had a
little bit of a mishap just now gorley
tried to count me in I didn't know you
were gonna Count Me In I never count you
in you never do and so I just on my own
started to say hey there and welcome to
as you were counting me in and it was
awkward yeah it's you know you were
actually sitting quiet waiting for us to
shut up yeah which I don't think I've
ever seen you do I well Sona is uh she
jabbers she's quite the jabber you
you're a talker you know that I mean I
like talking to Matt a lot about things
no no and so you were jibbering away and
you were babbling over here Matt and I
was just waiting for there to be a
moment for me to start the podcast I
don't even know what you were talking
about so you're complaining that Sona
and I have a cordial conversational and
applicable work relationship on the nose
yeah and you don't like that well I
think when it's time to get down to
business business
then you know it's time for me to crack
the whip but you're doing anything you
were just sitting there so we just
thought okay it's open season for for
Jenny and I I've seen you shoot remotes
and sometimes you need an action like
you need somebody to say okay you can
start so I think that that's probably
what you were waiting for oh yeah it
sounds like you know me better than I do
Sona I mean good for you you've observed
me in the field you've probably observed
me over the years uh practicing my craft
and uh you may know the real me I think
I do okay well we've I think so far
failed to find a good start this is a I
don't know it's but we haven't even
mentioned the show who we are and what
we do
so if that's what you mean by not off to
a great start I'd beg to differ that's
on you I'm going to maintain that I'm
not good at this I should have started
right away by saying hey it's Conan
O'Brien welcome to Conan O'Brien needs a
friend I didn't do any of that and I
think we're 40 minutes in at this point
I have a very I don't judge time very
well you know what I do have I have an
excellent sense of time do you I do yeah
meaning I can
um wake up in the middle of the night
and if you ask me to guesstimate what
time it is I'll say I'm gonna say it's
like 2 20 and then I'll look at the
clock and it's 2 18. oh my God because
that is some part of your subconscious
is always like one eye open it might be
but I I do have that I'm able to guess
the time and sometimes many times it's
within 5-10 minutes what time is it
right now well I've been podcasting for
a while so I I can't say but let's see
let's see we started
you see now
Jesus Christ I shouldn't have looked I
looked right at the huge Red digital
clock and he followed my eyes I don't
know if you put a gun in my head I'd say
203 and how many seconds probably 35.
incredible
um yeah it's just you know there's a
giant digital clock in the room I know
you were trying to test me just trying
to keep a sharp Buzz yeah I'm yokato I
gotta come at you you know keep you
sharp I like it I'm opposite with time
I'll be like I oh I know up in the
middle I know I know you are well Sona
what time is it right now be better than
me it's four o'clock
I uh I wake up in the middle of the
night I'm like oh that was a night nice
night of sleep and then it's midnight oh
that's the worst yeah I'm way off I
think you might be way off though
because you uh you get some
pharmaceutical help at night yeah you do
the uh the Edibles at night not every
night but yeah a lot did you because it
used to be
de regur you always did it yeah I always
took Edibles every night then Mikey and
Charlie entered your life yeah and to be
a good mom you probably can't have
Edibles right because you gave it
straight to them well no I uh yeah I
know well when I was breastfeeding they
slept great and then uh yeah I think
that there's a point where you're just
kind of like
[ __ ] it just go back to what I did
before but now you know they wake up
sometimes you're listening to advice for
new mothers the son of obsession
take a few gummies and [ __ ] it back with
more soda advice to new mothers and new
inmates
so no I am so when did you decide to get
back on the sweet sweet ganja I think
immediately when I was done
breastfeeding I was like okay now it's
time for for the sweet gunch to get back
into my life it's my thing it's my
advice you drink wine I take Edibles
would we ever do a segment where the
three of us get high
and it feels irresponsible it feels like
we're putting a message out there that
uh you know we think because it's a
gateway drug
um to fun gateway to fun you nerd
I'm sorry I can't have it I can't I'm
the Jack Webb I don't think it affects
nice reference uh is it yeah I didn't
get it that's why it just went right
through I was being ironic watch you
guys you're a fan of the old dragnets
right they're hilarious it was a show
um
they're really funny they're I mean not
intentionally but they're really funny
and they're constantly
um they're constantly yelling at hippies
it's not yelling squarest thing mankind
has ever produced yeah and and and they
will always
um rattle off my favorite thing is
trying to be educational but the hippies
were always over the top comical and one
of my favorite jackweb he did dragnip I
think he also did Adam 12 and once the
Adam-12 police it was a t I'll never
forget this exchange they they pull over
a what's supposed to be a hippie on a
motorcycle and their representation by
these really Square 1960s you know
comedy writers who are probably in their
50s of a hippie was he's wearing like a
World War One German Helmet and he's got
a he's got a monocle and he's incredibly
disrespectful to the police and and Reed
and Malloy the two cops are patiently
trying to tell him you know he broke the
law and he's like yeah you know pigs I
smell bacon all this kind of ridiculous
nonsense and then at one point they say
well we're gonna have to fill out an F5
report on you and the hippie says f i
what does that stand for foolish idiot
and Malloy or Reed says to him in this
case yes and the hippie goes huh and
he's like Monica falls out
like sick burn on the hippie
I love the depictions of hippies by
square comedy writers in late 60s and
early 70s TV it's absolutely hilarious
did you just watch that episode no no
that's burned into my brain there was a
Jackie Gleason variety show where they
were making fun of hippies and a hippie
uh runs out and he's carrying a sign
that says down with everything
and you know everyone's tolerating and
rolling their eyes at the unruly hippie
and then I think they scare him by
saying look out here comes someone with
a bar of soap and the hippie gets scared
and runs away I mean come on I swear to
God come on all this anti-hippy stuff it
just cracked me up as a kid and it still
cracks me up I'm sitting between the
biggest hippie son of always high head
in the clouds and then the biggest
Square Conan O'Brien that's true that's
absolutely very true you're not a square
though but you're uh
what's cool about me
yeah you know what I think you're a cool
guy seriously yeah name something that's
cool yeah about me yeah sauna seriously
I need some one thing one thing that's
cool one two three don't don't think
just try and buy time what you said
you're a cool guy what's kind of cool
about me can I tell you what I think is
cool that cool comedians think that your
comedy is cool
so you yourself I don't know but like
the people
the people you have inspired are cool
uh-huh and that's cool right but you per
you yourself this is the assignment
assignment it shouldn't be an assignment
you should just be just running off at
the mouth about all the cool things
about Conan O'Brien right now you know
you just I mean the cool thing about
Dragnet you make it very hard for me to
think about this stuff I'm quite the
Ladies Man
[Music]
the whole time I've I've worked for you
you've you've been in a lovely healthy
relationship okay what about this true
guilty yeah
um which is which is cool that's cool
yeah I throw down with anyone you've
seen me getting a few tussles in my day
ever I think that we always talk about
the one fight you've been in that's so
cool that you got beat up you don't you
don't get into fights and stuff you're
not like uh
and yeah all right I'm in a stable
relationship and I've managed to avoid
any kind of turbulence or violence
when troubles around he's home Matt
sleep
his wife made vegetables she's so
appreciative Conan O'Brien hey did you
hear about the big trouble that happened
downtown yeah where was Conan he was at
home checking his cholesterol apparently
it's 185 not bad for a man his age
hey did you hear what Conan's up to
what's he up to he just read a book
alongside his wife who was also reading
a different book
you
might run into him
that does sound pretty cool you are cool
you are
Commissioner Gordon just put out the
Conan signal
he was at home with the windows closed
and the shades pulled down
I don't like a breeze it interrupts my
sleep patterns you have a thousand
leather jackets that's cool whoa I do
have that's just because he cosplays as
the fonts yeah I go to birthday parties
for kids who don't even know who the
Fonz is and I cosplay of someone they
don't know I go you watch Barry he
watched the acting teacher on Barry
imagine him much younger in a leather
jacket and I'm the font and then they
escort me out of the birthday party
which you weren't invited to which I
wasn't invited to anyway yeah sir if you
come up if you show up in another
apartment or a birthday party you're in
serious trouble uh what are you talking
to Conan the fans hey